[music]
yeah yeah
Iwashita no
[music]
ah ah ah
your ingenuity
me
[music]
eh
The sense of [music] is
like this Wahhaha
ah ah ah
Ann Is tax okay
ah ah ah ah media is okay me
[music]
They're going to be a shop
[Applause]
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Is it a gei bahn [ __ ] I ah ha why what
are these guys padi yeah yeah yeah me wait are you okay?
It
looks like we can escape from our trip.
Let's go
.
d sen
Are you okay?
Error go away
[music
] I've never been
[music]
ni came bar
mar
yeah yeah yeah day It's Kido [music] [music] [applause] [music] It's getting dark
Bag  There must be a Kaiju electric motor inside a
lie I can't see the future
I have
no choice but to go on as it is It should be connected to the outside
People are good, but if they change, who the hell are
they?
I don't have it It
's too dangerous to act separately
[Music]
Warehouse,
so I didn't know just now
Sorry to see you carelessly Feeling, can you
give me back my gun just now?
I heard that some hemostats have special powers. Maybe that's why we're here
. What do you mean
, who brought us to this facility?
Where do we come from
Why are we
attacking [music] Why are we wearing bombed heads
I've been thinking about you for a long time It's
not like that I'm not the only one
ah ah ah
melanie dare
Yes, this is an office, isn't it? That's right, it's an office upstairs, but it's
probably
2 or 3 times,
is
n't it?
It's been like ruins for a minute or so There
's no sign of living things
First of all, it seems safe.
Look, I'm not looking for
weapons, and food, too.
It's being vandalized, but it
doesn't look like it was the work of that monster
. It seems like it was an emergency evacuation.
The building has already been completed and it
's run down like it's been used for 50 years I'm
somewhere  I remember hearing
[music]
Fluffy Heaven Warp Zone I'm surprised I'm not chestnut
What were you saying just now?
stand bs definition
true
my dad is a great dsd
hmm
then he didn't come to pick up Millie I don't
think
he did but he never picked
me
up before  Get away from here The
hemostats have attacked Let's all run to safety
Come on, yeah rar
pa
Milk
You stay here
Wait here for a minute I'm going to keep the hemostats from coming in here
And it's your father's order
Teacher, don't leave me alone-
[music]
Nemaa Usei
[Music] Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha My
brother
is going to marry
me, what are you going to do?
You know, there's no such thing as dating or anything like that
Papa,
you two are so cute
How can we be put to death together
?  Actually, I've been married five times I
can't help it I can't control
myself Every time I like a man I want him to be mine
Do you want to grab hold of it tightly?
How long have you been doing this
[music]
n ame
there's a lot on your face
?
Then you're out.
Your father is driving here
.  It depends on my luck
[music] It's
me I
can't even see a rich child and I'm going to die I don't think it's enough to say that
I need to flatter you There's no need to negotiate
Ah, yes,
my name is 6
The conditions are already  Saying wow,
Kiyoshi Hibiki
, once you've become a little son,
show me
.
like
If this guy falls, won't I become a legendary sinner
?
]
I can do it
But you're a pitiful fellow too My
friend and teacher Hayashi are my parents in the end
No one wants to help you
No matter
how much I beautify it, it won't be accepted in this world
[Music]
About to run away, everyone hurry up and get over here
Suoooooooooo
tan
[Music]
Don't harm the students
Come on, we're all still children
Days are searching
Haa I've invested more money in the classroom, so tell me
Can't you open it up and save it?
moving
tan
early
khan
yes
hey
ronan
f do you know
poo shi
ni
Abu says byannen star
na na na
par
me
denial
[music]
yeah
ni
[music]
where to
wh
aname
[music]
ani
haru
me
ani
ni
[music]
aname
me
[music]
uh ee [music] nn
Just to survive I
'll unite with the April people who fight together
But that's just a temporary alliance It's just a false friendship Next time it's a
bloody stick Sacrifice
[music]